we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p sometimes we
get positive voicemails sometimes I get
criticisms sometimes I get political
points or disagreements and sometimes we
just get really really angry people some
of them who swear at me and this is one
of those well I've watched your show a
couple times not because I've agree with
you but because I think you're so far
off base I just can't believe that you
can you know you can even view the
drivel that you do and you're talking
right now about sanctuary cities yeah
and I just think you're full of yeah I
like the parrot in the background or
whatever that was this type of anger
this is a problem okay this is a real
problem and you know I pointed out
yesterday I believed in pretty sober
insane terms how sanctuary cities are
not cities that are harboring fugitives
and making it so that rapists can evade
justice sanctuary cities are sort of
like the fifth amendment actually which
we discussed today saying we are going
to make the federal government do its
job in the same way that the fifth
amendment makes it so that law
enforcement and the legal system must do
their jobs as well and the best you
could come up with is to swear at me and
to call the program drivel the other
thing that I love about these messages
is when people express shock at how the
program is allowed to exist that's the
best when conservatives see the show or
listen to the show and they write in or
they call in and they say I don't
understand how this is allowed to exist
who is allowing this to exist how come
somebody hasn't shut it down which I
love hearing because then I say you know
who's allowing it to exist
every single one of the people in our
audience who says I'm gonna support this
work I think that by and large corporate
media has been completely taken over and
I am going to support something else so
it's because of the folks in the
audience who are supporting on patreon
and supporting via memberships that
show exists and it makes it so that no
matter what this guy wants to see happen
no one person can end the show no one
person can fire me because the bosses
are all of the members and supporters
and patrons and subscribers so thanks to
everybody we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today be a member be a
patron to get instant access and I'll
speak to you then